jetzt geht's los und ich weiß nicht ob
das klima mit diesem thema besser wird
ja wir schreiben den dritten november
2021 im logbuch der erde und es ist ein
trauriger tag zumindest für deutschland
es wurde die krone warnstufe in baden
württemberg ausgerufen und das heißt wer
dort auf normale weise am sozialen
kulturellen und wirtschaftlichen leben
teilhaben möchte wer also teilhabe
genießen will der muss frisch gewesen
sein geimpft oder einen pcr-test
vorweisen einen pcr-test für 70 bis 100
euro ist also seit heute nötig in baden
württemberg um beispielsweise in ein
restaurant zu geht ihnen ein museum das
von allen bezahlt wird das heißt ein
signifikanter teil der bevölkerung 30
bis 40 prozent wird von der sozialen
teilhabe ausgeschlossen in baden
württemberg ähnliche pläne gibt es in
bayern wo auch die tragschicht auf pcs
nicht ausgeweitet werden sollte und als
wäre das alles noch nicht genug hört man
aus dem umfeld der scheidenden
bundeskanzlerin ein blog downs für
ungeimpfte werde es geben doch dann war
schon das unwort des vergangenen jahres
ich hatte kost ist nie wieder in den
mund nehmen zu müssen und auch weniger
hoffe ich das ist realität werden würde
man ist also offenbar fest entschlossen
wieder einen teil der bevölkerung vom
sozialen leben deutschlandweit
auszuschließen in baden-württemberg zum
beispiel einem land mit 11 millionen
einwohnern
250 bewohner patienten intensiv an
intensiv verhandelt werden müssen
eigentlich sind die grenzen anderen
ländern ein lock down wird die soziale
spaltung weiter vertiefen also ein
doktor und ist gegen fast alle evidenz
weil wir nicht wissen ob die koma
patientin an im durchbrüchen bleiben
oder ob sie ungeimpften das verhältnis
schockiert je nach untersuchung die nach
land der eindruck da und setzt glücklich
die axt an den sozialen frieden und er
zeigt dass die regierung nichts aus dem
versagen im vergangenen jahr gelernt hat
lockt da und bitte nicht
also ich glaube das letzt gesagt dieses
offensichtlich nicht lernfähig das macht
mir auch große sorgen also denn wir sind
da in der gleichen situation wie exakt
vor einem jahr noch schlimmer eigentlich
in diesem frühling oder im frühsommer
wussten wir genau was sich entwickeln
wird so wie es auch im letzten jahr war
und haben wieder es nicht zustande
gebracht uns hier sicherer zu machen und
diesen ganzen unsinnigen
freiheitsberaubung ist es nicht aber
einschränkungen entgegenzuwirken das
entsetzt mich wirklich die komplett
lernunfähig politik und weder hören sind
wir müssen die besonders vulnerable
besonders sitzung genau die werden
wieder nicht geschützt werden jetzt
schon wieder mehrere alten und
pflegeheime zehn bis elf tote pro
einrichtung also man muss sich doch
bitte darum kümmern und die anderen die
momentan nicht bereits in sich zu impfen
muss man über reden nicht aber
überzeugen und nicht stigmatisieren ja
ich gehe noch eins erweitern wir müssen
doch auch damit leben können dass ein
bestimmter prozentsatz der menschen sich
nicht impfen lässt also immerhin bestehe
diese furchtbar ich glaube dass die
virologen eine besondere deutsche wie
soll ich sagen und getriggert haben in
den letzten anderthalb zwei jahren
nämlich dass alles immer
hundertprozentig sein muss es muss aber
hundertprozentig sein und wenn sie nur
99 prozent oder in unserem fall nur 80
prozent sind ganz schlecht ist muss 100
prozent corona des virus soll auch nicht
irgendwie nur in griff bekommen werden
sondern es soll verschwinden es muss
hundertprozentig weg und dieses 100
prozent ziel macht alle leute verrückt
und zeigt für unfreiheit weil es wird
natürlich nicht 100 prozent geben es
gibt auch bei anderen bedrohungen keine
100 prozent und wir müssen endlich
begreifen und ich weiß auch nicht was in
zweifel und außen hier weil ich
mittlerweile kann ich mehr weiß wie man
den politisch verantwortlichen klar
machen muss dass sie den gesunden
menschenverstand folgen sollen und nicht
100 prozent okt orten philosophie die
sowieso nicht sagen jetzt sehe ich bin
wirklich an der stelle ratlos ist immer
blöd in der talkshow sprachlos ist noch
schlechter davon also wer ja sagt immer
was
das ist ja gar nicht das ziel also man
hat ja auch schon frühzeitig gesagt dass
die herren um immunität erreicht es wenn
nicht alle zu 100 prozent geimpft sind
das heißt man ergänzen microsoft hat
heute erkannt dass die pandemie erst
dann besiegt es wenn 100 prozent
günstiger sondern fungiert also vier
würde ja auch davon gesprochen dass man
mit dem virus leben muss dass man einen
weg finden muss in diesen virus
umzugehen das heißt mit einer
prozentigen impfquote davon geht ja
eigentlich keiner mehr aus ich glaube
schon dass gruner nach wie vor sehr
ernst genommen werden muss wir hatten
jetzt zuletzt einige bekannte von mir
die auch doppelt geimpft waren haben
sich trotzdem mit corona infizieren und
man muss auch feststellen dass für
honorable gruppen einfach die
infektion mit dem virus nach wie vor
gefährlich sein kann deswegen darf man
das nach wie vor meiner meinung nach
nicht unterschätzen und gleichzeitig
muss man natürlich einen weg finden den
lock down zum gehen weil das ja das
letzte mittel sein soll und mit dem
virus quasi umzugehen und er ist ja nur
einer ist nur dass lockdown ist ja
eindeutig so witze auf verkauft nur als
pädagogisches folterinstrument gedacht
dann sollte er wirklich sagen wir
schließen euch weg so lange bis er alle
geimpft sein ist ein pädagogischer
zugang und ich finde so kann man mit
erwachsenen nicht umgehen dann muss er
schwer werden für die impfung aber nicht
die leute wegsperren aber was los ich
glaube ich glaube es war ein fehler
tatsächlich das impfen und auch
sozusagen dieses wohlverhalten gegenüber
den cola maßnahmen so moralisch auf
zulage weil das führt dann eben dazu
dass jemand der sich möglicherweise
anders verhält aus bestimmten drücken
dass der moralisch aber qualifiziert und
als schlechten menschen erkennt sie
daran die man irgendwie ausgrenzen muss
und man erkennt es ja auch im freundes-
bekannten- familienkreis wo man dann
manchmal so seltsam so aus gefragt wird
also da will jemand wissen okay wie
stehst du denn eigentlich zu den ganzen
maßnahmen bist bist du ja so
verheerend ist verlieren dabei
verbrechen freundschaften dran ich bin
doppelt gesagt dass immer gern ich hatte
das auch friedrich aber ich bin zum
beispiel nicht geimpft gegen grippe so
das interessiert aber niemanden
vielleicht wäre es sehr sinnvoll mich
auch vielleicht auch sehr
verantwortungslos sich gegen grippe
impfen zu lassen will das ist auch gar
nicht gleichsetzen bin ich nicht das
interessiert nicht sondern es ist
politisch moralisch aufgeladen und ich
frage mich woher kommt diese lust der
deutschen auch die haute moralische
moralisieren zu verhören das hat mich
wirklich da bin ich auch überhaupt kein
fan von von diesen moralisieren aber was
mir schon wirklich komisch ist ist warum
gibt es so viele die nicht geimpft
werden wollen
ich würde mir wünschen dass das mehr
wehren und ich frage mich ob man
wohin man noch mit der aufklärung mit
der überzeugung gehen soll also ich
meine die geschichte mit joakim ich war
ja interessant weil er einfach etwas
gesagt hat was er einfach so raus gesagt
hat und das darf auch machen aber dann
ist man natürlich als fußballer in einer
spezial situation hat auch gemerkt feier
dann auch sehr moralisch was da alles
passiert ist aber er war glaube ich ein
sehr großes spiegelbild von vielen die
einfach in großer verunsicherung sagen
also was euch jetzt aber für diese muss
sagen aber die würden sie sagen wie
überzeuge ich denn wie überzeuge ich
denn die leute zum impfen wenn ich sage
dass das eine kluge strategie ist zu
impfen und ich sage ist völlig egal weil
ich glaube sonst kriegen wir wirklichen
problemen wenn man kannst du nur mit
argumenten machen man muss ja aber lösen
von diesem argumentieren atom innen also
auf die leute losgehen das hatte ich ja
unfall das an der aburteilung von
chemisch in vielen medien oder in der
art und weise wie man jetzt über
helmbrecht her zieht dann werden
natürlich auch alle die ähnliche zweifel
haben werde ich mit in hab acht gestellt
und dann sehe ich habe mir dann gedacht
gewesen sondern eins sagen es ist
vollkommen legitim vor einer impfung
sorgen zu haben oder oder sich sorgen zu
machen was was man daran gespritzt
kriegt und was das in zehn jahren
vielleicht so völlig läge die natürlich
ist das legitim einfach mal hier und an
den pragmatismus der menschen genau weil
man muss aber auch sehen was corona halt
macht und wenn longo weit kommt und man
kann halt einfach aufgrund von vielen
zahlen zu erstellen hey das mit dem
impfen ist wahrscheinlich die bessere
lösung im vergleich zum corona bekommen
gefährlich ist also ich glaube auch dass
man deutlich mehr aufklären muss über
die korona impfung weil was wir jetzt
auch gesehen haben ist das verschwörungs
erzählungen wahnsinnig zugenommen haben
und das ist eine sehr sehr gefährliche
tendenz die auch nicht unterschätzt
werden darf weil wenn so krasse
maßnahmen sozusagen kommen dann passiert
das vielleicht auch dass menschen sich
in ihren privaten angegriffen fühlen
weil es eine vermischung ab zwischen
politischer ebene und der privaten ebene
und sie ziehen sich an der stelle zurück
und bewegen sich in teilweise vielleicht
in chatforen wo es schreckliche fake
news auch gab und das ist auf jeden fall
auch eine gefahr für das gesamte
gesellschaftliche zusammenleben weil
natürlich auch haben sie schon mal thema
es gab auch einige fans von herrn
lauterbach also ich würde das nicht
rechtfertigen dass man sich abschließend
kann man bitte nicht da gibt es genug
verrückte aber es ist nicht so dass die
eine seite jetzt immer nur mit nur mit
lauter lauterkeit zugange gewesen sei
und die andere hat sich von vornherein
vorwand gewesen gibt auf beiden seiten
solchen und solche und man muss sich
wirklich mit den informationen die man
hat sein eigenes bild machen und darf
auf keinen fall sagen leute praktisch in
ihrem mensch sagt ihr menschsein
absprechen hat die gefahr sehe ich wir
haben momentan immerhin 77 der
erwachsenen die geimpft sind ich denke
wir kriegen es vielleicht bis 80 85 aber
irgendwann ist dann auch mal gut mit dem
was man einem freien land erreichen
jetzt immer genannt worden als das
manchmal viel absolute erwachsenen der
wand so ganz toll aber gegen jetzt 10
285 und wenn ich glaube wenn 85 prozent
geimpft sind dann ist wieder neues
problem irgendwie hat die politik ein
instrument erkannt wie sie wie sie
freiheiten einschränken da war ich schon
dass das ist ja wissen was es braucht ja
auch bei ihnen vorher einmal auf das ist
der über tag über den tag hinausweisen
gedanke der mir sorgen macht wenn das
einmal durchexerziert worden ist wird es
bei anderen themen wie möglich wieder
entdeckt die umwelt ist einzeln also
wenn man es schafft leuten klar zu
machen oder einsperren dass sie nach 22
uhr nicht mehr raus dürfen wegen corona
dann kann man das mit also noch viel
viel viel viel mehr recht auch machen an
dem man sagt also nach 22 uhr mit soviel
noch in die erdatmosphäre ausgeschlossen
bleibt und man übernommen denn da können
nicht nur ein paar sterben sondern alle
ich wundere mich ehrlich gesagt bei
vielen über die doppelmoral die die
ungeimpften kritisieren als gefahren
schleudern aber im auto mit dem handy
telefonieren was auch immer gefährlicher
ist als also die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
man damit einen schaden zufügt ist viel
viel größer als wenn man ungeimpft ohne
masken risikoabschätzung ist sowieso
transaktion ihren deswegen also das
können wir menschen genauso wenig wie
die langzeit themen aufgreifen wir haben
unsere risikoeinschätzung völlig verquer
das ist immer so aber wir müssen ja nun
auch sehen corona ist ein risiko wo und
wie kriege ich das in griff man müsste
mal die gegenfrage stellen wenn wir
jetzt einfach sagt ja das finden wir
alles nicht gut und wenn dazu viele
anweisungen sind und überhaupt und wir
wollen aber was wollen wir denn machen
also wie mache ich es als idee wenn ich
sage ich möchte allen die freiheit
lassen ich möchte aber von corona
schützen ich möchte niemanden moralisch
angreifen was ich uns auch sehr ich habe
die angriffe
auch sehr gut endlich mache 21
antwort endlich die logistik in griff
kriegen endlich die booster impfung zur
verständlich genug krankenhaus aber die
hamster ende werden die leute machen die
griechen glaube dass das alles diese
wofür ist der staat denn eigentlich
zuständig ist der staat wirklich
zuständig den menschen ihr leben rein zu
regieren ich glaube nicht der staat ist
zuständig die logistik bereitzustellen
wenn ein problem auftritt und es ist ja
bis heute nicht geschehen es ist bis
heute einfach nicht geschehen dass der
staat die logistik beherrscht und sperrt
deshalb die leute zu hause ein und da
komme ich richtig in fahrt also die
antwort lautet die logistik in griff
kriegen und man muss aufgaben machen die
man machen muss und man muss
letztendlich auch der verantwortung der
einzelnen bei einem gewissen punkt geht
es gar nicht anders an der freien
republik musste der verantwortung des
einzelnen trauen ich muss angebote
machen ich muss aufklären aber es gibt
dann immer noch leute die aus gründen
die wir alle gar nicht kennen und
weltanschaulichen religiösen gründen
medizinischen gründen was weiß ich sagen
ich mache das nicht ich mache das nicht
und dann ist irgendwann auch wirklich
mal schluss mit der pädagoge sierung des
volkes und das ist wirklich meine sorge
dass dieser prozess so lange
hinausgeschoben wird dass man sich daran
gewöhnt dass wir eine große überschrift
haben die der staat setzt und je nachdem
wie groß die überschrift ist dafür ins
privatleben angreifen